we have to be are they closed tomorrow
you woke up today at 5:00 p.m. but
here's the thing here's the thing though
he's still playing destiny no we used to
play remember Jade and I used to just
cry together we plan twice we play more
than you did yeah I'd have any gear you
know gear right right I jump on my
little like speeder I know how to play
in your yeah we're going to there the
Lord of the fine and then you guys would
just kill everybody I would die multiple
bits of playing yes but yeah you don't
play anymore
now Red Dead or nothing I'm into smash
again I'm gonna smash bros this is why I
got excited when I saw this did you
don't have smash brothers do you I don't
have it but I'm gonna tell you something
about this device they're called what
they call switches and I've been playing
stardew valley I don't even know what
that is it's a simulation gasps she
hates it riot
stardew valley yeah it's a farming game
and you have the farm
oh it really makes farmville it's not it
looks a little bit like um Animal
Crossing a little bit but it's not just
a farming game all right there's mines
to be explored you can go below this is
creatures to fight you have a wife I'm
happy you have a wife right next to you
right now my beautiful girlfriend yeah
do you take care of her you know how
many [ __ ] do you know how he feels
he's gonna stay oh well he takes care of
penny and Hailey his wives on there yeah
well I married the blonde one Haley she
her she's the most ungrateful wife I've
ever what does she say Jenny's a
librarian the penny helps the kid she
babysits kids in the library
sure and she's got but but we know we
know penny
yes but Haley you know what she does
what her favorite item everyone has a
favorite item right yeah her fader I am
his pink cake all right Peter hate pink
cake oh say a pancake with a pink no
it's a cake but that's pink a pink cake
are we talking about the same thing
right now no not [ __ ] right so what
Haley does to find her every day is she
just sits there by a tree right she
doesn't do anything and so I you know I
married her and she says is the first
time you've lit up this whole things in
it that's like ridiculous she goes yeah
my sister tried to feed me um parsnip
soup and you know I don't like health
food hey yeah did she like breakfast
burritos you should take this vehicle
yeah do you ever go to dune next to
there - I like dune I like down [ __ ] you
man these are right it's okay pretty
good dude what do you get meat I get
there the rap that you always get Yeah
Yeah right before Jose one there bread
there whatever that like they're there
pita whatever that is so good
[Music]